je pense que hahahaha et e et bah ça va
ça va jouer à la fin vers tirs au but je
pense avec je pense qu'ils vont pas
lâcher la sphère pronostics exacts pour
ce premier quart de finale entre la
pologne et le portugal
ce jeudi soir au bar girassol
d'elancourt les supporters de la seleçao
ont fait beaucoup de bruit dans ce
restaurant portugais pour encourager
leurs protégés
pourtant le match avait mal débuté pour
les coéquipiers de cristiano ronaldo
laisse t il encaisse un but dès la
deuxième minute de jeu puis vient la
délivrance renato sanchez égalise d'un
tir dévié à la 33e minute
les fans exulte le score n'évolue pas un
partout à la fin de la prolongation
direction les tirs au but le portugal
l'emportent 5 à 3 des portugais sont
qualifiés anthony semaine on viendrait
du mais tout ce qui est notre peuple
c'est qu'on est unis dans la douleur et
dans la victoire
nous ce qui nous intéresse est d'aller
le plus loin possible
si content parce que l'on déniche
n'allons pas nous intéresse supplice la
seleçao portugaise affrontera mercredi
prochain à lyon le vainqueur de la
rencontre pays de galles belgique
le restaurant portugais girassol sortir
à nouveau les drapeaux lusitanien à
cette occasion